vous
bonjour et bienvenue dans une autre édition de
diagonal Jess le seul
programme d'échecs sur Internet à ma droite est
le lancement international du grand maître Illawarra
désolé si vous voulez voir l'un
des spectacles précédents, ils sont assez faciles
à trouver sur le réseau Web du canal  site et
vous pouvez voir beaucoup de choses intéressantes
et ils ont aussi le français et l'espagnol je le
crois sur oui fonctionne benicia
broadcast et tout ce que vous pouvez
trouver sur l'affaire de Grenelle Kruk
et le web ça va pas cette
semaine  nous allons examiner en particulier
certains coffres britanniques et
événements d'échecs britanniques, nous allons commencer par
regarder le mémorial Harry Golombek, le
prix Terrance Chapman et les quatre ncl que
les Britanniques viennent de fuir et qui seront
dans l'événement après ça  nous allons
regarder un jeu offensif fantastique entre
maintenant Minh et Gormley et dans la dernière
partie du programme, nous devrions
couvrir des nouvelles internationales sur les échecs,
donc la première partie du programme le
événement d'
accord exceptionnellement cette semaine, nous
allons examiner plusieurs événements qui se sont
récemment terminés. Le premier événement est le
mémorial Harry Golombek qui a été joué
récemment à Paignton.
pendant longtemps, je ne sais pas si vous le
connaissez pour le connaître du tout non pas tellement
je sais juste à propos du grand trophée
sugano qu'il a donné à l'abscisse chaque année oui
oui eh bien il a laissé de l'argent dans son
testament aux Amis  d'échecs et ils ont
décidé qu'il serait approprié d'
organiser un tournoi en son honneur un
tournoi commémoratif et cette année c'était
le 50e anniversaire du Paintin Ches
Ches Congress peindre des parcours dans le
sud-ouest de l'Angleterre c'est très agréable et
ils ont décidé d'organiser le Grand  Le tournoi Master à
côté de lui avec son
legs et curieusement la peinture et la
première peinture au Congrès a en fait été remportée
par Harry Golombek, vous savez qu'Elwha non,
bien sûr, l'ajusteur ne sait rien
sur l'histoire anglaise des échecs, mais
bien sûr, il est intéressant d'apprendre qu'en
fait je ne le savais pas non plus jusqu'au
début d'aujourd'hui, maintenant le tournoi était un
tournoi de grands maîtres, c'est
qu'il y avait essentiellement plusieurs grands maîtres et
eux beaucoup de maîtres internationaux et
le  l'idée était que les
maîtres internationaux feraient des normes de grand maître
quel était le grand maître pas de ministre
Nutella c'était un six points sur 90
donc c'était une catégorie de pertinence qui
est assez difficile par rapport à la
catégorie tendue parce que c'est le même nombre de
points qui  vous devez faire oui pour
eux car non c'est vrai je pense qu'ils
pourraient faciliter la vie de perdre au lieu d'
avoir un joueur de 2600 qu'ils auraient pu avoir
comme un joueur de 2300 et auraient quand même
dû faire le même nombre de points
c'est vrai oui c'est  complètement juste en
dessous était ok donc le joueur français ou la
Fontaine y a joué et peut-être à
cause de ces difficultés
difficultés supplémentaires il n'a pas
fait oui donc c'est  un peu dommage
parce que lorsque les organisateurs organisaient
très souvent des événements Grandmaster comme
celui-ci, ils essayaient de le rendre aussi simple que
possible et il
y a deux catégories qui sont beaucoup
plus faciles que d'autres mais c'était une
catégorie très difficile d'accord les
résultats réels de  le tournoi a été remporté par
deux grands maîtres John none d'
Angleterre et Klaus Bischoff d'Allemagne
qui ont tous deux obtenu cinq ans et demi sur les
neuf matchs, puis juste après eux à la
troisième place égale, il y avait un autre
grand maître mark hebden bien sûr est
très bien  connu en Angleterre de
Leicester, puis des
maîtres internationaux, il y avait d'abord Robert
Fontaine, le maître international français
, puis Matthew Turner, tous deux
de jeunes maîtres internationaux très talentueux, mais
ils ont tous deux terminé sur cinq, ce qui était
essentiellement à un point du GM Norwich
car bien qu'ils '  re cherche
qui est comme tu dis tu es peut etre a
cause de la categorie difficile
car Robert Fontaine il a debute
tres  eh bien n'a-t-il pas oui je pense qu'il a
appelé le téléphone beaucoup de sikhs ou
quelque chose comme quatre ou cinq donc il était un
il n'a qu'à marquer deux points sur les
quatre derniers matchs sur les deux matchs perdus à
cause de la difficulté des adversaires ouais
le  leurs points forts bien plus tard dans
ce tournoi, nous allons
jeter un œil à l'un des jeux c'était un
jeu merveilleux très beau jeu très
intéressant qui sera plus tard mais
maintenant nous allons passer à un autre événement
qui vient de se terminer  En Angleterre, c'est
le prix Terrence Chapman maintenant Terrence
Chapman était en fait un junior prometteur
vers les années 1970, mais a ensuite
décidé de faire quelque chose de plus utile avec
cette fois, il a décidé de créer sa
société informatique, une société de technologie de l'information
et maintenant, bien sûr, il est très riche, ce qui
est peut-être  une leçon pour nous à l'époque je ne sais pas
bien sûr que vous devez faire un choix
quand vous êtes un jeune joueur d'échecs et que
certaines personnes essaient d'aller d'une autre
manière après avoir eu quelques regrets donc je
veux dire juste c'est vous devez  écoutez
votre cœur oui, soit vous avez un
style de vie très intéressant en tant que joueur d'
échecs professionnel, soit vous pouvez gagner beaucoup d'
argent, mais peut-être pas les deux, d'accord, il a
décidé de créer un certain nombre de prix
pour les juniors anglais prometteurs et je
pense que le premier prix ce  l'année était
mille livres qui sont allées à
Kurt Nick qui a remporté le championnat du monde des moins de 18
ans il y a un an rare récemment en
Espagne très très bon joueur joueur très très
talentueux et il y avait un certain nombre
d'autres prix de 500 livres chacun et
le lauréat avait  la chance de jouer
un match contre le fort grand maître
qui était Murray Chandler maintenant le match a
pris un nombre assez intéressant de
tours parce que le premier jeu a été tiré
mais ensuite chaque joueur avait
un blanc pour les quatre tours suivants donc
Murray Chandra a gagné un jeu alors  pert a gagné
un match à chandler un puis finalement pert
un hors du jeu, puis ils ont
décidé d'arrêter et de faire un match nul
afin que le match soit en fait tiré trois
tous et th  Il y a quelque chose d'autre
chose d'intéressant à propos du tennis Chapman
est en fait qu'il parraine également le
Grand Prix qui était autrefois le
Grand Prix de Lee et avant cela, je ne me souviens même pas
comment il s'appelait Je ne sais pas
si vous savez que vous êtes je sais  c'est oui mais je
ne l'ai jamais utilisé car il est spécialement
conçu pour les joueurs anglais, c'est
vrai, c'est évidemment beaucoup
de tournois ouverts le week-end en Angleterre
qui sont presque inconnus dans les autres
pays européens, ils préfèrent les tournois plus longs à
9 tours et chaque tournoi
dans ces  ces tournois du week-end campent
pour un certain nombre de points dans le Grand
Prix tardif maintenant le Grand Prix Chapman et la
personne qui obtient le plus de points à la
fin sur 200 victoires est une
somme d'argent assez importante, je ne sais même pas
combien  c'est moi ça valait 3 000 livres
de toute façon ok c'est
que c'était le match était un match nul si bon
résultat pour Bert qui fait match nul dans un match
contre le plus fort et le maître est un
très bon résultat maintenant  il est passé au
quatre ncl qui est la ligue britannique des échecs
, curieusement, il n'est pas géré par la
Fédération britannique des échecs, c'est qu'il a en
fait été lancé séparément, mais il est
maintenant devenu incroyablement réussi et cela
semble très étrange a toujours semblé très
étrange il y a de nombreuses années qu'il
y avait  pas de ligue d'échecs en Grande-Bretagne ou en
Angleterre alors que dans d'autres pays il
y a des fuites d'échecs nationales, elles
existent depuis longtemps oui bien sûr
surtout en France en France et en
Allemagne en Espagne il y a des
championnats par équipe très forts en France je
pense Adams  joue sur les quelques années
d'il y a deux jours, c'était Kasparov
qui a couronné Nichols qui a joué et et donc
bien sûr dans un pays entièrement européen, il
y a des compétitions par équipe très fortes
oui et bien que la ligue britannique
ne soit pas si forte en ce moment nous
n'ont pas autant de joueurs étrangers forts mais
il y en a quelques-uns et bien sûr le
joueur britannique est très très fort cette
année l'événement ressemble beaucoup à la dernière
fois  ar il semble y avoir des équipes très fortes
woodgreen bien sûr vous avez
Spielman babbar dans le quartier de m et et d'
autres grands maîtres forts
champions en titre de Slough qu'ils ont remportés les
deux dernières années avec Tony miles et gourou de la
démangeaison et beaucoup d'autres joueurs forts
Aaron  échelle d'été Colin McNabb et pas
à moi cette année eh bien je ne jouais pas
le premier week-end car le sponsor
m'a dit qu'il ne prenait pas cela
cette année très au sérieux mais nous
verrons si c'est vrai il y a aussi en
vainqueur dans Victor Knights  ancien de Victor
Knights qui s'appelle maintenant index IT l'
histoire intéressante derrière cela est que
index I t est la société créée et dirigée
par le grand maître David Norwood et
le maître international de Mike Michael
Hennigan qui les a rendus très riches
et David a décidé de parrainer cette équipe
et donc ça s'appelle maintenant l'équipe informatique de l'index, en
gros, ils ont tous les joueurs de l'année dernière
et ils en ont signé quelques autres,
ils ont signé Mark Hebden et aussi
Mickey Adams et les divers  d'autres
ils ont une équipe très très forte et
ils cherchent évidemment à gagner cette
année et il y a une autre équipe qui
semblait très forte c'est Guildford ils
ont aussi une équipe plus forte que
oui d'accord le premier le premier jour c'était
samedi non  des résultats particulièrement intéressants
toutes les équipes fortes un deuxième
jour cependant était très intéressant car
il y avait un gros affrontement entre le champion en
titre slough et wood green maintenant si nous nous
souvenons la saison dernière, Wood Green
poursuivait Slough jusqu'à la fin et
le dernier match était censé  être
entre un bourbier et un bois vert, mais ensuite le
bois vert a glissé contre la barbacane
et le slough un avant même qu'ils aient eu à
jouer si lentement le vert bois uni est un vrai
choc et cette année le vert bois a
classé le bourbier sur chaque planche mais
en fait le résultat  était une victoire 5-3 pour
slough à nouveau, donc Slough bien que le
sponsor m'ait assuré qu'ils
n'allaient pas essayer de gagner le titre, je pense
qu'ils pourraient changer d'avis maintenant un
peu d'int  les résultats au repos de ce match
Tony Miles a battu Babbar avec les
pièces noires qui était le premier match à
terminer et l'appelle également macnabb a battu
John Leavitt résultat très important
également d'accord, c'est donc l'événement que nous
allons maintenant transmettre au  le jeu du
jour donc le jeu
et le jeu que nous avons choisi cette semaine est un
très très beau jeu quand je
parcourais les jeux du mémorial Harry Gorham
Beck c'est le jeu qui
s'est vraiment démarqué ça te choque quand
tu  regardez-le d'abord et bien depuis, il a
appris qu'il avait remporté le prix du
meilleur jeu de 250 livres dans le tunnel qui, lorsque
vous verrez le jeu, vous ne serez pas surpris,
alors jetons un coup d'
œil à cela  jeu encore donc ça se
joue entre maintenant mec sur le gamma D
qui est un jeune maître anglais oui donc
c'est une ville ouverte sur la Sicile oignons natif
60 quelle est la sécurité de cet
ordre de mouvement oui les grandes subtilités ça s'arrête à
des variations de blancs le blanc peut  Je ne fais
rien de mieux que jouer  Chevalier à c3
ici, ce qu'il a joué les autres
variantes conduisent juste à une égalité facile
pour les noirs donc en fait c'est l'
ordre de mouvement le plus précis pour les noirs je crois
qu'il s'arrête par exemple si nous revenons si
blanc si noir prend immédiatement sur d4 à la
place  de jouer Knight f6 vous savez
, puis la nuit prend après Knight f6 le
meilleur coup est Knight c3 mais les blancs peuvent
aussi jouer f3 par exemple et les défenseurs
nous n'aimons pas cela et puisque l'idée est
de jouer probablement avec c2 c4 et
ensuite obtenir  longue équipe oui frappe l'assistance
alors oui et après chaque accord bien sûr,
il est possible de passer à la position précédente 30 50
g six et de nombreuses possibilités mais pourrait en
avoir six évite simplement toutes ces
possibilités pour cela, évitez Quint
XD car il n'évite pas XD pittoresque car
c'est  assez intéressant en fait parce que
dans ce qui m'a battu avec l'étiquette verte d il y a
quelques années parce qu'ils
doivent ensuite se rappeler que c'était vraiment une
attaque forte sur le très intéressant
et vous pouvez le trouver dans un nouveau manch  ester
livre
un vraiment vous ne voulez pas le regarder
donc par Steve white peut jouer Queen prend
d4 ici Quint XD pour cela mais c'est
sans l'idée de jouer à CPAC pour n'importe quel
Myers c'est juste si noir joue
Knight c6 ici alors Bishop  b5 va se
transposer dans notre jeu mais comme vous le dites les
noirs peuvent jouer un 6 a-6 près de l'instance donc en
retard XD pour ou non la ligne la plus pointue de
la sicilienne on peut probablement dire le
national avec 5 a 6 Fou g5 encore les
navettes avion oui ça  est
évidemment c'était la ligne c'était très très
populaire et j'ai commencé à jouer la
nuit dans les années 1970 c'était la grande ligne
mais elle est devenue tellement analysée que beaucoup
de gens s'en abstiennent comme le blanc l'est
mais il semble qu'une dissolution a conduit à un
faux tirage avec la bombe empoisonnée oui en
fait quand j'ai mis plusieurs variantes j'ai
joué en tant que noir il y a de nombreuses années contre
Bishop g5 et je pense que trois d'entre eux ont tous
conduit à une pleine paille ce qui était assez
ennuyeux quand on joue un joueur plus faible
oui oui  c'est donc un gros problème
de Bish  op g5 est que c'est juste un match nul donc
il corrige f2f 4 et ici Tony tu recommandes
96 on peut le redire dans ton livre
oui c'était booké gagnant avec Ernesto non
ce n'est pas c'est un mec facile au Nidal
c'est un livre que j'ai écrit récemment  qui a
eu de très bonnes critiques, donc si vous voulez vous
précipiter et l'acheter, je le recommande vivement
, je recommande le mouvement chevalier c6 et je le
justifie dans le livre et je pense toujours que
c'est un très bon mouvement et ils sont
instantanément dedans  les championnats de France
récemment tout le monde semblait penser
que c'était un bon coup oui en effet il y avait
des gains gratuits les noirs jouant 96 contre
l'aigle netif qui est une défense de ce
coup Bishop g5 le premier jeu était un match nul si
long jeu noir un sur le dernier match
un blanc donc un sur beaucoup de gratuit ça va
pour cette ligne en fait je ne pense pas que
quelqu'un ait joué la meilleure variation pour le
noir donc tu nous dois encore faire
des recherches sur mon équipe pour notre prochain
match contre ego right machette 7 Queen  un moyen
gratuit c'est très naturel de
développer  ng pièces idée de
château saisonnier Quincy 7 a été joué
kelson IBD 70 c'est une ligne principale c'est
la ligne principale c'est vrai cela a
été joué par Bobby Fischer contre
Spassky en 1972 c'était la ligne principale
de cette variation à l'époque et c'est la
ligne principale maintenant  donc g2g pour aussi la
différence de fou jouable oui à l'époque
il y a 20 ans oui Fou d3 était le coup
et beaucoup de lignes sacrificielles très fortes
avec des tactiques partout mais les noirs
ont une très bonne ligne contre Fou d3
qui est h 6 h-6 et  dans cette position,
vous signifie qu'après le fou d3, bien sûr,
le coup le plus principal est à nouveau un
b5 après le fou e3, c'était le coup principal
b5, puis il y a un sacrifice de reine
pour les blancs et menant à un duo
également, il semble donc que le fou  différer n'est pas si
dangereux à ce moment-là ouais aussi que h6
est bon ouais h6 n'est pas si mal l'idée
de l'âge de l'évêque pour voler g5 tu aimes
cette idée je réponds à ton téléphone utha news
système brun si système Braun ouais Shoji
4b 5c calmar normal  Nous faisons  Je ne veux pas faire de
château court avec les noirs trop rapidement
parce que nous avons peur de nous marier
oui Bishop prend f6 nuit x g5 97 tout cela
est bien connu et aussi la ligne la plus nette
je pense que la ligne la plus forte pour les blancs est
de jouer f5 oui ceci  c'est la
ligne principale et en fait blanc sacrifie
la jeep avec Jack mais il continue juste
son initiative hehe il attaque
e6 et il veut
attaquer très vite sur l'aile roi parce que dans la
nuit en fait positionnellement dans un sens
noir c'est mieux  parce que vous pouvez voir qu'il
a un pion central supplémentaire ouais et il
a des chances d'attaquer le long de
la ligne de haute mer ouais avec être quatre et
tour pour voir un 8 et et aussi vous voyez l'
épon blanc c'est une cible
pour le noir parce que le noir peut  attaquez-le de
plusieurs façons avec le fou en b7 et la
nuit en c5 donc Oh mr.  carré oui la
nuit ne veut pas y aller et donc
blanc très souvent il s'appuie sur la tactique
il a un gros avantage de développement ses
rois déjà en sécurité donc il essaie d'
ouvrir la position attaque le blanking
oui le principal avantage pour blanc c'est
pas  l'avancée dans le développement de pièces
car ce n'est que trois pièces contre
trois mais c'est juste une réponse réponse
très avancée oui vis vis à vis du film 5 mais
bien sur dans des facteurs long terme c'est
mieux pour les profs noirs d'être des boutiques sur
le pion extra central comme toi  disant que les
blancs agissent très rapidement Fou d3 Je
n'aime pas ce coup personnellement Je pense
que le cinq est le plus fort le coup le plus fort
simplement ennemi des complications Je
pense que les blancs ont dû essayer de
jouer quelque chose d'inhabituel sortir son
adversaire du livre  mais je remercie Danny
Gormley, c'est un bon joueur, vous savez qu'il
sait ce qu'il fait et il a
plutôt bien réagi.
nuit de retour en
e2 et c'est cette ligne avant oui d'accord alors
voyons être pour la fin ce2 puis
Bishop e7 menaçant 95 et d5 et oui
cette position semble assez ok 44 noir
bien sûr donc 95 a été joué h4 donc blanc
ne veut pas sacrifier  un pion ils
veulent jouer f5 sans donner g5 avant la
nuit ce2 ce qui est très logique et pas de
fou d7 il n'y a pas on dirait que
tu es le roi noir va s'échapper
du côté le plus long c'est vrai la
première fois quand j'étais très jeune  et j'ai
vu ces longs châteaux dans la nuit de j'ai
été très surpris je pense que c'était un jeu
de poissons et cela ne semble pas très
logique car le côté réel de la reine a l'
air très aéré là les pions sont
ils sont le bip sur le  sépale et
ils ne défendent pas le roi mais en
fait les pièces noires défendent le
roi et les pièces blanches sont du côté du
roi et les pions blancs donc en fait
c'est en fait sûr de mettre le
roi noir du côté reine dans cette ligne alors
côté roi côté roi  les blancs
joueront f5 h5 g6 chargeront tous ces
pions sur le plateau et c'est très souvent
mat oui parce que c'est l'attaque pour les
noirs est une installation assez lente donc
juste vous devriez jouer la capsule courte
avant de pouvoir faire ne serait-ce qu'une seule menace que vous
vous accouplez donc  c'est inutile ouais
ce coup King be one c'est un très bon
coup dans beaucoup de lignes siciliennes il
n'y a pas de menace immédiate pour le roi
mais en fait le roi est toujours bien à l'abri
de b1 et c1 parce que si on regarde quand
les châteaux blancs de l'autre  côté vous mettez
son roi immédiatement en g1 dans le coin
où c'est sûr mais quand vous Cass le long
de votre mouvement plus loin
du coin et c'est pourquoi les gens
gaspillent un coup pour jouer le roi être un c'est
c'est c'est un très bon pas
mouvement préparatoire prophylactique sachez que c'est le mot
que je recherche et par exemple ça
évite de se faire mater sur la ligne c
et c'est une bonne compensation car la
tour est tout de suite un lieu actif ouais
et quand tu magasines château tu viens  il
faut jouer un autre coup de regard supplémentaire donc c'est
de toute façon vous devez passer deux temples
vrais donc ça peut être un maintenant un coup très
intéressant je pense que original est le
bon mot à 75 eh bien l'idée
est bien sûr d'utiliser l'évêque sur le savon b7 dans  de l'
info du pion c'est l'idée principale et l'
autre idée peut-être de commencer car
après la partie qui est presque forcée elle
prend f6 oui c'est normal coup Bishop
prend de ne pas utiliser les cases noires oui
car noir n'a plus de noir Bishop
blanc a  guellen pousse un évêque noir au
carré noir c'est vrai donc ces
évêques ont de bonnes perspectives d'attaque
oui c'est l'idée et le spectateur
devrait garder un œil sur cet évêque
car il va faire une terrible perte
dans ce jeu car il ne va pas
beaucoup bouger  mais ça va être le
joueur clé du jeu alors pourquoi continuer
très logiquement dans le plan 24 en mettant la
pression et donc II six pion fou
c8 c'est un pas c'est un coup qu'on
n'aime pas non c'est un retour oui c'est  vrai
mais il  doit défendre e6 et en fait, il
a une idée tactique très très claire, il
met l'évêque sur CIT, mais dans
quelques instants, il sera capable de le
déplacer à nouveau correctement, donc c'est
juste un mouvement tactique insensé comme ce
natif  gratuit parce que bien sûr peut-être que cinq
étaient une menace de prendre le cavalier en d4 d'une
manière ou d'une autre, mais si j'affichais oui,
cela semble très étrange car en
fait, le blanc bloque l'évêque
fous en f6 est en diagonale de sa propre volonté, cela
semble très étrange mais le jeu
montrera qu'il a une idée beaucoup plus profonde et la
chose la plus importante est qu'il doit empêcher les
blancs de jouer un 5 qui
exposerait son roi au centre droit donc
c'est une petite différence de mouvement
surtout la différence parce qu'ici les
blancs ont joué pour déplacer f45 mais quoi  que
se passe-t-il si juste la plaque blanche 23 disons
bouger comme ça parce que pour garder le
daytona fermé pour garder ces
structures bien, ouvrez-le bien j'imagine que
le noir pourrait amener son évêque CI à
certains j'aime 60 et il pourrait  même être
tenté de Castle kingside plus tard à
droite je ne sais pas je pense que la trempe
III était une suite oui Michael bien sûr que
tu as raison le mouvement 20 FF vient de fermer
toutes les idées d'attaque pour le poids et
aussi en prenant la pression de e  5
il permet aux noirs de jouer d5 plus tard,
ce qui est une autre idée typiquement sicilienne
donc ici bien sûr le fou n'a plus rien
à faire en c8 donc il est de retour à
sept
Neji libre on peut voir l'idée des blancs nuit
h5 attaquer le fou et f6 long
château  on no whites play Knight g5 pourquoi
pas timbi huit donc c'est encore pareil un
coup prophylactique sois libre je sais qu'il est
temps d'ouvrir les lignes d foi oui
c'est le contre mouvement sicilien typique
normalement blanc les chars sur l'aile
normalement côté roi mais  en
contre-attaquant au centre, les noirs
obtiennent très souvent l'avantage c'est une
idée très typique qui se produit se produit
énormément la plupart du temps, les blancs passent la
majeure partie du jeu à essayer de l'arrêter mais
ici, comme nous pouvons le voir, un blanc n'a pas  été
très  réussi lors de cette nuit de oui
sur Jeffrey's a complètement
perdu sa place dans cette position et i-25 n'est
pas si actif pour comparer avec le noir
Bishop mv7 il est très très fort donc le
blanc a un meilleur noir car de meilleures pièces
sur le centre le plus fort donc juste la
position est  déjà beaucoup mieux pour les
noirs ça reprend d5 un coup que je
n'aime pas trop je ne connais pas le
texte du groupe e5 et pas de fou avant c'est l'
idée hmm car les blancs espèrent en fait
contrôler avant si les noirs capturent sur  e pour
un blanc reprendra probablement avec la
nuit g oui lequel qui a été huit
ng trois ouais et il aura
un carré très très fort en e4 et le fou en f6
il est bloqué par le pion en e5 il semble
très faible nous pourrions même si  il peut plus tard
échanger l'évêque b7, il passera une
bonne nuit contre la mauvaise position d'évêque
et il est également important de dire que
la nuit sur c5 défend le carré
e 6 donc cela donnerait des options blanches au
planaire g5 v six ouais contrôlant le  d8
cases  c'est assez important donc
bien sûr la nuit xe4 n'est pas de déplacer les blogs
veulent jouer au groupe d car c'est comme une
épingle
épinglant l'évêque ici donc nous avons pris
d4 juste pour échanger quelques pièces contexte
Bishop prend d7 et bien sûr il semble que
c'est  d'accord pour les blancs oui on dirait qu'il a
réalisé ce qu'il allait faire une fois
après que les noirs aient repris le fou il
va apporter une pièce en e4 et il
va jouer sur les cases claires
contre cette danse Greg Bishop en fait je
pense que quatre-vingt-dix-neuf pour cent de  les
joueurs réfléchiront à la pièce à
reprendre en b7 avec ici mais les noirs
trouvent une idée brillante une
possibilité incroyable oui donc c'est juste le super
mouvement par défaut être libre il est une pièce en moins
et ne prend même pas la peine de reprendre l'
évêque c'est comme si c'était un  bonne idée bonne
idée pas tellement d'options pour les blancs ouais
comme on peut le voir l'une d'entre elles est juste de
ramener le fou en g2 mmm Fou g2
réfuter par un beau coup ouais Chevalier en c4
c'est en ce moment il y a deux mar il y en a
plusieurs très  de grandes menaces ici, ils ont quitté
Dixie pour est le principal taxi à anneau pour se
mate en un oui il y a aussi des menaces de
Knight c3 check night e pour vérifier et
night d pour vérifier désolé oui et aussi
lisse comme Queen pour voir trois été
la reine à  e5 Je pense que Quincy à lacy
de Neji à I assez Je veux dire, c'est que le prochain
coup sera avec l'un de ses libres et il est
impossible d'éviter de le rendre impossible
à éviter si rooty 192 mat si 2193
gagne la reine et défend également déplacer la
reine taxi pour mater  bon donc juste ça
suffit on a pas besoin de 23 ou 25 contexte ça
on sait pas c'est trop tellement la
montagne donc après d3 juste impossible de
repartir avec le fou et les blancs
choisissent très logiquement d'éliminer le
pion sur  différent oh pas encore une heure
bien encore on s'attendra à ce que les
noirs reprennent sur b7 ou deux
Queenie cinq nuit menaçante sur être aussi
mais il a trouvé un autre est très très
surprenant mouvement nuit 8 pour incroyable
encore une fois nous pouvons dire avec toutes les menaces donc
je  crois que 93 est un gr  mangez en un je vois si vous
checkez et le prochain coup sera une
attaque de carte de test oui Jack aussi possible est
Quincy gratuit perdez matin soit pour moi c'est
tout bien oui mais mais c'est déjà
beaucoup c'est déjà pas donc deux
possibilités alors que c'est très sympa
J'aurais aimé voir le visage de White en
fait après ces deux derniers
coups, ça a été intéressant je pense que si
j'étais blanc déjà été plutôt surpris
donc ici c'était possible que Bishop prenne un six
menant à un beau coup Quincy free
running mate sur Vito Pinto Pinto v2
des fusées pour défendre 95, nous ne sommes donc
pas pressés de jouer à cette reine un
Quincy à un chèque pour l'instant il est temps de faire un
chèque King see to night text a six et
les dernières pièces entrent en action
la tour un enfant arrive à c  8 avec
des effets dévastateurs oui oui donc ici 94
est très fort et il faut
prendre cette pièce ouais contexte un téléphone
eh bien jetons un coup d'œil à cette
position pourquoi il a deux pièces supplémentaires
et le noir n'a que deux pièces
développées et  ses rois s'ouvrent je veux dire que
cela ne me semble tout simplement pas possible tout le
monde à cosabella ce qui est impossible
cela ne semble tout simplement pas juste que les noirs
devraient gagner cela oui oui c'est
assez surprenant bien sûr parce que son
attaque avec seulement deux pièces sur le  la tour
sur le commerce ne vient pas à c 8
parce que l'évêque contrôle donc
c'est trop seulement des pièces d'attaque ce n'est
pas vraiment vous pas assez de quincy 3d pour
toi si c'est krissy trois c'est le
peu la grande menace correspond
bien sûr à la version bêta  oui à cause de l'
évêque et de la reine sur la longue diagonale donc
matin pour écrire ceci et pourquoi il a un
certain nombre de façons de nous arrêter
c'est tout c'est
tout ouais donc trois possibilités quand je suis
désolé aussi nous pouvons lui faire vérifier la reine f4
mais après l'évêque b5 nous utilisons juste
la reine et la reine voir une reine I
un chèque andrew est local au
dépistage car est également un autre de
possibilité défensive je ne pense pas que ce soit très bon
car je me souviens avoir analysé le Sénat perdu
alors disons analysons Queenie au
lieu de défaut ouais en fait quand j'ai
regardé ce jeu je n'ai pas trouvé de
victoire claire pour les noirs après que Queen mange oh  Je
ne sais pas si vous l'avez regardé du tout
oui j'ai un regard tranquille un coup d'oeil rapide mais
bien sûr on dirait qu'un blanc n'est pas
en si grand danger car la
course de la fusée est très fortement protégée par l'évêque la
nuit s'ok  gagnants qui est protégé
et donc juste toutes les pièces se
font ouais donc c'est pas fait c'est
possible de jouer avec attends maintenant évidemment
noir aimerait jouer sa route vers c8
car alors Reine I une sera faite
mais cette case est couverte par le  évêque
sur b7 par hasard, je pense que le
mouvement évident est que King prend évêque et ensuite je
suppose que 94 fait quelque chose avec ces pièces
oui donc cela a forcé un noir Blake
vérifiera parce que sinon après la nuit prend f6
il est trop tard alors vérifiez que King va voir
à  Je sais qu'il n'y a pas de m  mangé non et comme
vous le dites, le rocher sur h1 est défendu mais
il a toujours une très très forte attaque,
nous pouvons voir qu'il peut prendre beaucoup de pions
avec échec, vérifions que a au roi
était cool à d1 car la route
arrive  jouer
exif ou vérifier Kinney un pour que le roi
s'échappe mais oui mais c'est très mauvais pour le
noir oh oui il semble qu'il semble presque
perdre car le roi devient faible
la peau blanche est très sûre sur le chevalier en
e4 est une justice très forte donc je pense  Je
pense qu'il ne devrait probablement pas vérifier le
roi, il devrait essayer de ramener sa
tour dans le jeu en c8 d'une manière ou d'une autre,
mais pas absolument sûr que c'est
complètement gagnant, mais c'est une si
belle idée qui mérite de gagner oui,
c'est bien sûr mais très  justice pouces je
pense bien vous savez je veux dire dans la pratique
pratique du jeu d'échecs vous savez les joueurs
aiment la serviette ils ont fait de manière fantastique avec des
choses qui n'étaient pas tout à fait solides
et des gens comme ça je veux dire que c'est très
très difficile quand vous faites face à une
attaque à  défendre je rem  braise perdre contre
vous ceci sur un réservoir de sondeur et ainsi de suite est
que c'est un monde donc finalement l'
erreur arrive quelle erreur ouais parce
qu'ici bien sûr, comme nous l'avons vu, Queenie
était le bon mouvement avec quelques
possibilités défensives en d4 c'est juste un mouvement
qui  était le jeu ouais après que Bishop
ait pris d4 ouais la grande différence est maintenant
que la nuit g3 est sur les prêtres par
exemple si après Queenie dans certaines
lignes et il peut insérer très très souvent,
il peut les prendre sept et alors il
sera  menacer la nuit en g3 si la
nuit bouge alors il peut gagner la tour sur
un h1 oui cela donne à l'attaque noire une
force supplémentaire ok de toute façon si on veut
comparer la ligne avec Queenie pour
savoir qu'il n'y a pas de pone en d3 et le
fou en  f6 ne sera pas sur s'il vous plaît après 94
donc ses nombreux avantages beaucoup d'inconvénients
beaucoup mieux oui 34 est définitivement une
grève non il essaie une autre défense qui
Queen a4 check nous devrions être cinq donc c'est
le même adversaire Wizards III
Quincy one Queen a one check  Roi c2
Quint XA 2 donc bien sûr l'idée était peut-être
juste de donner le carré d gratuit pour
le roi mmm mais bien sûr ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas une solution oui c'est évidemment l'
idée mais en fait le roi le troisième jour
sans rien devant  ce n'est pas
il n'a aucun moyen de revenir au
deuxième rang oui elle n'a pas l'air en trop
bonne santé fait l'autre oh oui non non c'est
probablement en train de perdre et aussi des pièces noires
entrent en action Rudy un
chèque King avant que Bishop ne prenne g3 c'est un
très difficile de savoir après le texte de King b7
si c'est possible au prochain coup ce sera un
avantage adverse pour les noirs ouais donc
duvet incroyable le tank King a gratuit
avec d3 ouais c'est en fait une erreur
oui nous devrions jouer autre chose ici
car en fait écran de cinéma plus fort  F
à vérifier parce que si vous pouvez voir si le blanc
va en e4 vierge, vous pouvez mater en un seul mouvement
basculer n'importe quelle forme 8d correcte afin que nous
puissions mentionner ce roi avant de conduire
à mater donc Rudy pour Nate afin que le roi d'entre
nous aille gee pour vous  pour toi et n  ot et
maintenant h5 piste h5 check ok je ne vois pas l'
idée en fait alors King prend de tels bébés
forcés et Queen prend f5 et la
cigarette qu'il vient de faire est rock h8 et
avec un compagnon un mouvement et bien mon ordinateur a
trouvé bougé comme Queen ta check  afin que vous
puissiez dégager voir à quel point cette édition rouge est mauvaise, a
déclaré vérifier avec juste une
position complètement perdante, donc la reine des
deux gagnait par position forcée contre
, mais à la place, le joueur anglais a
joué la reine doit jouer le désarroi
rugby free tech King va à G  pour un
nokia X be 7a c'était peut être un peu de
temps bien sûr oui c'est un très très
bon tacticien oui mais non bien sûr c'est
un point supplémentaire pour les noirs
et le Queen e2 est menaçant donc juste
c'est une position gagnante sans aucune
compensation pour  Mouvement défensif de la reine blanche f1,
mais maintenant il a maintenant un manteau noir qui
va très facilement avec le contrôle c4.
x oui pas de cases pour
la nuit ma demande pour la nuit oui
car oui pas d'espace tout est sur
svp Quincy un c'est une attaque de contour
contre le fou et g3 ou pas je pense que
c'est très simple contexte g5 tour prend
g3 texte de Quinn f5 dans un très  bon mouvement
à l'intérieur du point de cet avion des idées pour
s'accoupler avec la NFL g4y ne peut pas prendre la tour le
troisième jour parce que ce sera je peux
regarder cette ligne oui ça ici oui c'est moi
euh-huh Rudy libre alors g4 compagnon d'accord
c'est  assez gentil pote avec juste deux reines
couple de Paul Quinn au téléphone oui Quincy
à vérifier finissons vite les abeilles avec
ce jeu king b8 whooped x g5 Queen h7
check candy pour Rudy pour check à la
fin à la fin par conception mais il y a en
fait une finale  déplacer nous pouvons voir oui le
roi des trois minéraux héberger la reine pour
vérifier le roi des deux perdre la reine après
le d2 en facteur pourquoi oui le noir pourrait
prendre la reine mais a en fait un faux
roi puissant mariages tard dans un quickie
pour l'enregistrement à l'âge de 22 ans Quinn  prends ça pour
ok bien sûr  c'est pour le spécialiste de la
perfection parce que nous pouvons simplement prendre la
reine sur le vainqueur de l'année avec le profond
sur les services juste techniques ouais deux
autres mouvements pour finir tongji un est
forcé je ne suis pas vraiment bien nous ne prenons pas
la reine immédiatement nous venons  prenez la
reine sur la richesse après parce que
le prochain mouvement Queen f1 est forcé alors nous
pouvons prendre la tour avec
oui et ensuite nous pouvons prendre la reine
avec échec et application de toute façon ce n'est
peut-être pas tout à fait valable mais une
idée si merveilleuse qu'elle mérite le successeur
est un très bon jeu alors comment pouvons-nous résumer
c'est un jeu eh bien c'était peut-être que je
devrais vous poser cette question est une
nuit très très forte Le
jeu d'ouverture des blancs n'était pas précis à 100% et les
noirs avaient une très bonne position en fait
il  avait une très bonne position peut-être
sans avoir à commencer ce
sacrifice en deux pièces mais après le
double sacrifice de la paix, il a obtenu un très
très fort un char très thématique le long de
la diagonale a 188 et la chance 11 de Misty blanc
oui c'était probablement un double
problème oui j'imaginais donc dans un
jeu aussi compliqué en fait les coups noirs
beaucoup d'entre eux sont très très bons il a raté
un mat plus simple mais à part ça il a
joué beaucoup de coups très forts super
jeu donc aucun homme  aleksandar avec blanc
contre normalement l'année alors je pense que d'accord
et c'est le jeu du jour pour le
jeu et maintenant nous passons au reste de
l'actualité
et aujourd'hui nous allons examiner un certain nombre
d'événements tout d'abord il y a le
Rubenstein  mémorial un autre
tournoi commémoratif après avoir regardé le
mémorial Harry Golombek semble devenir
assez populaire tout cela ces
événements commémoratifs oui tout cela est poussé du coude le
moyer vient de terminer oui mm-hmm d'accord
Rubenstein était très très connu très
très fort très populaire échecs  joueur,
il est en fait né
juif polonais et il jouait je pense à l'
olympiade de Buena zaraz en 1939 comme beaucoup
de nuages ​​​​jouaient à l'olympiade en
Argentine en 1939 lorsque la seconde
guerre mondiale a éclaté  et bien sûr, ils ont décidé
de rester en Argentine et qui peut les
blâmer et mais la nuit de congé a en fait décidé
de passer le reste de sa vie en tant
qu'Argentin a pris la nationalité argentine a
joué pour les échecs du côté argentin et
est devenu intentions et objectifs de la tournée
Joueur argentin il est très très  bien
connu pour autre chose qu'il a prêté son
nom pour guérir ou vous voulez dire qu'il y a un
najdorf sicilien c'est exactement ce que je veux dire
c'est un Casillas comme ouverture utilisée dans
le jeu du jour et bien sûr il est
toujours utilisé par les meilleurs joueurs oui il l'a fait
Je n'invente pas vraiment l'ouverture, elle a
été inventée principalement par Je pense que je vais
peut-être obtenir d'autres
pinces à chèque ce mouvement un six très fort
mais il a été le premier
joueur vraiment fort à le jouer beaucoup et comme
cela arrive souvent quand le fort  le joueur
joue une ouverture puis l'ouverture a tendance
à prendre son nom ok et cette corde le
mémorial était à Polly Neate monsieur droïde
regarde toi alors maintenant garçon attends ouais en
Pologne quoi en Pologne dans les années en
P  olish en Pologne et le vainqueur était
Boris Gelfand qui a marqué six ans et demi
sur neuf devant van wel e'en
shérif oui mais le bon fonds est en fait
en grande forme en DM
il a de nombreux résultats solides comme en
coupe du monde comme nous  disons que la semaine dernière, il a également
bien joué dans le projet de loi, je pense que j'ai
terminé deuxième, mais ma
petite amie est en fait de retour ouais, ils
aiment que les choses jouent à 2700 oui, je
pense que le shérif Van Whalen aurait pu
rattraper s'ils en avaient un au dernier
tour mais  n'a pas réussi hmm d'accord
il y a des nouvelles très intéressantes
il y avait en fait un match de démonstration
en dehors des Jeux olympiques de Sydney Anand et
cisaillement sont allés au village olympique de
Sydney et ils ont joué à des jeux rapides,
ils étaient tous les deux des événements très excitants 111
était  une ouverture d'idole je crois très pointue
je ne l'ai pas vue en fait et ils étaient
tous les deux tirés au sort et il y avait aussi une
donnée simultanée par un jeune
joueur australien contre un certain nombre d'
athlètes olympiques évidemment l'idée de ça  est
de vulgariser les échecs pensez-vous qu'il
réussira un tel événement bien sûr c'est
très bien pour les échecs juste d'être
reconnu comme un grand sport bien sûr ça
va fouiner populariser les échecs le
jeu d'échecs que dire d'autre
bien sûr c'est un très bon  dans sa
fantastique forteresse et pensez-vous simplement que la
poitrine devrait devenir un sport olympique,
ce n'est pas clair bien sûr, ce
n'est pas clair parce que c'est un point d'esprit
avant tout, donc quand vous voyez une vache
Louise ou je ne sais pas Cathy Freeman
ce n'est pas  le même genre d'
athlète que sur le par exemple disons
emblématique oui c'est vrai mais quand on
regarde les Jeux Olympiques maintenant et le nombre de
bien je suis un peu grossier Mickey Mouse
sports qu'ils ont comme je n'en ai pas  connaissent
toutes sortes de choses marrantes comme la
nage synchronisée et le trampoline
et mais bien sûr ces sports sont
des sports physiques ouais le sport de l'esprit c'est
difficile à accepter je veux dire personne ne peut
comprendre ce qu'il fait oui donc
c'est moins c'est plus difficile  pour le rendre
acceptable pour le public et
pensez-vous que peut-être que la poitrine sera un peu
perdue aux Jeux olympiques parce que même maintenant,
nous voyons avec les nouvelles qui sont
vraiment dominées par des choses comme le 100
mètres, le 400 mètres et beaucoup d'autres
sports  ne sont pas vraiment diffusés de
toute façon et aussi quand vous regardez les
échecs comment ils n'auront que comme je
ne sais pas quelques médailles d'or ou
quelque chose comme ça quand et pour des milliers de
joueurs d'échecs qui y vont oui non je
ne  Je ne sais pas mais aussi la formule n'est
toujours pas décidée je veux dire si c'est si les échecs
dans l'armée sont aux jeux olympiques quelle
sera la formule sera un système de coupe
ou de championnat on ne sait toujours rien
et c'est difficile de trouver une
idée intéressante  oui est-ce que le pont fait
une sorte de démonstration chez eux je
pense que je pense que le pont aussi mais c'était
Vizio ce sera dans le prochain prochain dm2 oui je
ne sais pas ce sera difficile mais
bien sûr si nous pouvons être inclus dans cela
c'est un super  chance pour tous les
joueurs d'échecs et vieux che  st fans ouais ouais alors
peut-être que personne n'est vraiment sympa c'est
comme si la question des échecs devenait un
sport c'est aussi beaucoup dont on
parle c'était vraiment beau ou mauvais temps
devra être testé contre la drogue ou pas les
échecs deviennent en fait un petit  le sport en France
cette année c'est pas tout le monde oui non c'est
reconnu par sondage ou ministre
ministre tu sais donc c'est un
changeur de budget pas tellement je veux dire en fait c'est
presque des signes avant mais bien sûr on
peut dire qu'on est des sportifs et ouais on
peut dire à tout le monde mon sportif au lieu
de simplement dire que nous jouons aux échecs, la seule
différence est faite pour moi car j'ai reçu un
diplôme national de formation
oui d'accord super parce que maintenant que ces
certificats nationaux nationaux parce que
c'est un sport et que je suis un entraîneur national
super donc je  j'ai un très beau certificat
à raccrocher mais à part ça comme vous le
dites il y avait une autre différence en Italie
c'est reconnu comme un sport et
ils ont fait des tests de dépistage de drogue dont je
ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez des années
les dirigeants une histoire et certains joueurs comme les
jeunes femmes sont complètement opposés à
ce test de dépistage de drogue parce que je pense que c'est vous qui
ne devez pas boire de café et ne pas
fumer de cigarettes sous donc c'est une
formation variée pour les joueurs d'échecs ouais
peut-être que j'ai parlé à eddie murphy avec de la drogue
testé en Italie aux tournois des porteurs et de Jojo
et et il semblait estimer qu'il continuait à
boire beaucoup de café
et il s'en est tiré d'accord, je passe
à une autre chose intéressante les
championnats américains maintenant je ne sais pas si  quelqu'un a
remarqué que les États-Unis  Fédération quelques
problèmes d'argent, ils ont dit qu'ils
n'allaient pas pouvoir organiser le tournoi
cette année, ce qui aurait bien
sûr été une grande honte, la dernière nouvelle est que
oui monsieur Sarah juan a sauvé le
tournoi avec un ami de son Erik
Anderson qui est apparemment un  l'investisseur
a trouvé cent mille dollars pour
organiser le tournoi et cela ressemble donc
aux championnats américains de cette année
qui commencent le 24 septembre, ils
ont déjà commencé et ce
sera l'un des plus forts de tous les temps, je
pense que tous les meilleurs GMS américains  disent
qu'ils vont jouer le premier prix est
de 10 000 $ les autres prix sont également très
bons, donc il semble que ce serait un très
bon événement, donc à partir de rien, il semble que
oui, monsieur a réussi à sauver le
tournoi, c'est une usine au-dessus de la cuisine
seul un joueur américain peut jouer à ce
tournoi oh c'est un tournoi international que
je viens d'entendre juste pour les personnes
de nationalité américaine et de nationalité américaine
et je pense que c'est exactement mis en
place une fondation  sur la
fondation de la poitrine de Seattle, je pense qu'il vit à
Seattle, c'est assez évident, donc ça a l'
air d'être très
intéressant ou je n'ai pas encore vu
de nouvelles de la même manière pour moi, donc je
pense que nous avons terminé avec cette émission
et donc peut-être qu'il est temps pour nos
conclusions d'étape ouais avant de terminer,
mentionnez simplement que si vous voulez regarder
des programmes précédents, ils sont probablement bien
meilleurs que celui-ci et cliquez simplement
sur les archives d'accord, donc cette fois
nous avons dû  regardez quelques
événements d'échecs britanniques qui devraient se terminer récemment et
un très beau nidal par Danny Gormley
un paignton du prix de la brillance et
bien sûr toutes les nouvelles internationales que
nous avons à portée de main sont et j'aime juste
dire que je suis Tony Costin grand maître anglais
mon  l'invité est Illawarra lance le
Grand Maître français jeune joueur français
prometteur était prometteur pas si prometteur
maintenant et merci d'avoir regardé ce
programme si en effet vous l'avez fait